معنى من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز نفهمك
اولا القراءه العسكريه لابعاد الاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه بالمسيرات
لقواعد عسكريه ومطار في الاراضي الروسيه
للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
كانت الاهداف تقع في في المطلق داخل همم
الاراضي الاوكرانيين باستثناء بعض الحالات
التي تم استهداف اهداف في بلغراد على بعد
عشرات الكيلومترات من الحدود السياسيه
واستهداف جزيره القرن التي الاوكرانيا
يعتبرها اراضي اوكرانيه وروسيا يعتبروها
ومن ثم جسر كرش الى غير ذلك الان نحن امام
تحول همم اا غير غير معقود وحتى في بعض
الحيوانات غير متوقع لكن المتابع بدقه
للتصريحات الاوكرانيه كان قد يتصور ذلك
لانه منذ اسابيع ووزاره الدفاع وبعض
الوسائل الاوكرانيه تشير الى تصنيع طائره
مسيره اوكرانيه اجري عليها تجارب وحتى
الطائره التي تم اختبارها في اخر مرحله
كان مكتوبا عليها عباره ترجمتها للعربيه
سانتقد ليس اسم الطائره انما مهمه الطائره
تاتي في اطار الانتقام والمعلومات عن هذه
الطائره المسيره وهي تطوير لصناعات
السابقه سوفيتيه مداها يصل الى الكيلو متر
وبزنه 75 كلغ الاهداف والقواعد التي تهببت
بالعمق الروسي سواء او القائد الاخرى تبعد
ثلاث مئه اي تقريبا 480 كلم وهذه القواعد
يوجد بها طائرات قاذفه استراتيجيه يو 150
و يو 95
وشركه ماكس همم نشرت صور لقاعده انجلز
وتبين الاضرار اذا نحن الان امام تحول
واضح في اداره المعركه وان الاهداف
الروسيه التي اعظم مدى 1000 كيلو متر حسب
المعلومات عن هذه الطائره قد تكون اهداف
يمكن الوصول اليها ويمكن احداث اضرار
هذه الطائرات المصريه
اوكرانيا وهمم يعني لم يكن معه هذا انا
اكرهنا مثل هذه الطائرات المسيره هل هي
الصناعه يعني اوكرانيا محضه ان ربما تم
تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه التقنيه لتصنيعها
وبالتالي دفع الحرج عن الدول التي كانت
متهمه بانها تزود اوكرانيا او تزود روسيا
بمثال التكنولوجيا
يعني اولا امريكا
تجويدها بطائرات درون متطوره كبيره الحجم
هي تملك او زودت بطائرات بيرك دار ولديها
ترخيص بانتاج طائره بيرك دار هذه الطائره
وحسب المعلومات وحسب ما اطلعنا في بعض
التقارير هي طائره سوفيه طائره الدرون
سوفيتيه تم تطويرها والبناء عليها
وبالمؤكد هناك استفاده من همم على سبيل
المثال طائرات ميريدار هناك استفاده من
حطام طائرات همم الايرانيه شاهد الى غير
اذنيه عمليه جمع للمعلومات من من التقنيه
المستخدمه في الطائرات الاخرى والمعلومات
وحتى معلومات صادر عن وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيين اشارت بوضوح لتجربه اولى
وثانيه
وقبل تقريبا في الاسبوع قبل الماضي كان
هناك تصريح واضح ان هذه الطائره ستغير في
مفاهيم المعارك الحاليه
الاستراتيجي شكرا لك